um lap top
hoje estamos aqui em uma armadilha que
houve vanderlan sonho descobre e põe
porque tem muita uma armadilha pela
maneira como atuava e pronto e fazer em
casa
essa medida tem que ser construída em
ter no osaf perto uma da outra então
metro e dois metros e para comer tenha a
china situação então eu fui propriedade
e fish emprego a cerca e um ramo que
está na terra e plantar armadilhas para
capturar animais de grande porte onde o
jeans enviados e outros animais de campo
grande e pronto como vocês podem ver
agora tem uma lança e essa lança com
toques mais grossa flor e tem que ser
ver muito mais força ela irá fazer uso
de um animal só haver um entendimento
somente podem fazer está na ilha mas
vocês só poderá usar brincar
sobrevivência de timon tem lá porque em
perigosa que podem deixar é montado em
casa mas é um feminismo expor criança
com essa ajuda acordo que o terrorismo é
muito interessante um mecanismo
diferente e me faz esse tipo de
questionamento e pronto vocês hoje
deveria refletir
apesar das várias trilhas existentes
ajustar a altura né da lança em que
apanhei no chão
quem quer apanhar vant por paz lembrando
tem mais pontos foram de mais de 3 mil
após mais algumas bandas têm que subir a
lançar a tv tem que ser evitada
é a altura do animal
o rio animado ao tocar vai ser um beijo
que é bastante sensível que planta
kikuchi a funcionar só deus deve ter
pensado eu fosse ele